For most of us, January
was a normal month at school.
We learned together, we ate together,
we played together.
We hung out with each other every day.
But as the coronavirus spread,
our world was upended.
In February, hundreds of millions of us
lost access to our schools.
By the end of March, nearly every school
on Earth was closed.
Closing schools
creates distance between us.
The distance slows the virus.
It reduces hospital visits.
It saves lives.
We're proud to help flatten the curve,
but now we need your help to keep
the pandemic from flattening our spirits.
Here's how you can help:
It's graduation season for millions
of students throughout the world.
We can't attend or support
2020 graduations in person,
but that doesn't mean billions of us
can't support the graduating
classes of 2020 online.
We need your help, graduates
and supporters of graduates,
to make this year a worldwide celebration
of the hopes, the dreams,
the ideas, and the futures of an entire
generation of young people.
With support from TED, we've outlined
all the ways you can get involved
with this worldwide celebration here.
We are the students whose lives
have been impacted by COVID-19.
Together, our ideas will define
the world future.
Visit TED.COM/GRADUATION to sign up
and support our future today.